hi i'm drew gooden and this is the wired
auto complete interview
[Music]
it's worth pointing out that there's
another drew gooden arguably more famous
than me he played in the nba for i think
like 15 years
does drew gooden um
yes did drew goodin
create youtube so a lot of people assume
that this is a joke because one time i
had this like throwaway line in a video
where i was like i invented youtube i
made it myself i was just kind of
hammering away on my computer one day
and all of a sudden i had a website and
it's awesome you should check it out
youtube.com
lots of videos on there they're awesome
did drew gooden
do it for the vine vine was an app much
like tik tok uh people made six second
videos i made some for a couple years
before i did youtube one of the popular
ones on vine i didn't make it was the
song where someone said do it for the
vine i did for a little bit but these
says no i do it for the tube
did drew gooden
win a streamy
yes i did i was actually really excited
about that i did not expect to win at
all my wife and i were watching the
award show and a lot of the awards they
don't like make a big thing about it
they just kind of do this like lightning
round where they go through several
different awards and that was one of
them and it was just oh by the way drew
gooden i was like
what i was i was genuinely shocked but
yeah i'm really proud of that it was a
it was a cool thing and they gave me a
trophy so i have the trophy not with me
but i own it
does drew gooden have a podcast no
not currently my wife and i started a
podcast with the intent of doing one
episode every week i guess forever it
was called the little stinker radio hour
and i thought we had an interesting
story about our relationship because we
met on on vine and we did long distance
for a bit and we wanted to kind of offer
advice too for people are in that
because it's it's tough to go several
months without seeing you know your
partner and i think that was worth
sharing but then once we got to the
second episode we were like all right
now what do we talk about we made it
two
weeks
and then we stopped all right does true
gooden
have a job this is a very judgmental
question
do you have a job yeah i mean i think
what i do is a job i make time to sit
and work and i film and edit and editing
can be a lot of work too i like doing
every part of the video myself contrary
to what maybe some of my family members
might think yeah
i work hard-ish
sometimes
how old was drew gooden
when first vine my first vine
was probably 2014 and it was me filming
what i thought was a really funny
commercial for mayonnaise
and they're just like
if you want mayonnaise you gotta use
this brand of mayonnaise and that was
the whole vine so that really
you know set off my career trajectory
from a great starting point for sure
how did drew gooden
and danny gonzalez meet danny and i
actually met at vidcon
several years ago we had been in a short
film sort of that vine put together
called camp unplug we went to this camp
in wisconsin camp juan de weiga we shot
there for a few days and then i remember
we went to vidcon i think shortly
afterwards but danny's awesome he's one
of the funniest people i know and we get
compared to a lot which i find a
compliment you know he's super talented
and funny so if you think that we're
similar that's great
how drew gooden
joined team 10 team 10
was a an internet conglomerate started
by jake paul and
he had this course you could take where
you sort of learn how to be in team 10
and i made a video about that
unfortunately i did not ever join team
10 i did go to his live show and i got
to watch them all perform i was in the
same room as team 10
if that counts how did drew gooden spill
the water one time i was on cody koh's
podcast and
i
was uh nervous to be on this podcast
because i was a big fan of cody and i
didn't want to make a fool out of myself
and sure enough i'm just sipping a
bottle of water and i set it down and
just knock it over almost got it on like
all the recording equipment pretty much
the worst thing you could do in a
situation where you're trying not to
look like an idiot not one of my
proudest moments but
that's okay
how many
subscribers
does drew gooden
have 3.3 million as of now but the goal
is 1 billion so if you want to help that
cause go subscribe to my youtube channel
and we should hit 1 billion subscribers
pretty soon
all right what is drew gooden
doing now i'm glad you asked i'm doing
uh the wired auto complete interview
what camera does drew gooden use
panasonic
lumix
g
150 that's a pretty good camera it's
good for
for sitting down and uh staying
focused in one spot otherwise if i move
around it's not as good of a camera
because the autofocus isn't very good so
if you're sitting down and making videos
that's a good one to use
what state does drew gooden
live in i live in florida good old
florida a lot of my friends will send me
sometimes you know you'll see a headline
it's like florida man does the most
insane thing that anyone's ever done and
they're like was this you and i say yes
because it is usually me
what happened to drew gooden
i don't know is there something i should
know about was there an accident i was
involved in which drew gooden plays
basketball which drew in plays
basketball professionally is the other
drew gooden for sure he's much taller
more athletic in pretty much every sense
than me but i do own a basketball hoop
in my backyard so technically i would
say we both play basketball
which drew gooden
can dunk
not this one well the fun thing about
owning your own hoop is that you can set
it to any height you want so if i want a
dunk i'll bring it way down and i will
dunk regulation size probably probably
not
true good and all-star so this is
probably the other one i'm going to
explain how the nba works uh because i'm
kind of the authority on this in the nba
there's all-star teams that you could
vote it into every year so i think
they're probably asking if he got voted
into one of the all-star teams i didn't
get any votes but i do not know for
certain if he didn't when did drew
gooden retire
ugh i wish i could retire if you ask my
family going back to the other questions
earlier i already did retire as soon as
i quit my you know real job and started
doing youtube that was the day i retired
so if you're going off that logic then
like 2017 i retired as a 23 year old and
i don't do anything all day ever it's
the best
why does drew gooden
say guy
for a long time i didn't know how to
start my videos because a lot of people
are like what's up guys or they have
like a catchphrase or a nickname for
their fan base and for a while i was
calling people little stinkers and then
i didn't really like that that much i
sort of just started doing that and i
was like is this gonna be my thing
forever i don't know how i feel about
this but then instead of saying hey guys
once i said hey guy
and people seem to think it was funny so
i've been saying it pretty much every
video why do i say it
because it's funny
druid and fan fiction oh boy
one of the videos danny gonzalez and i
made together was about
the funniest fan fiction i've ever read
in my life that someone wrote about us i
think one of us married jake paul i
believe it was called house of gold that
was a really funny video to make because
we hadn't read the fan fiction
beforehand there was so many insane
twists in it every time you think it
couldn't get any crazier it did
so i would recommend watching that video
if you want to learn more about my fan
fiction and my
reaction to it drew gooden picture of a
hot dog i also have a website to show
off my web design skills where the home
page is a picture of a hot dog and then
you can add all these different toppings
to it i've got a corn dog on there
nachos hat so you know really just some
crazy stuff on there
drew gooden christmas movie so i've made
a lot of videos about
weird christmas movies which is pretty
easy to do because i don't know if
you've noticed there are so many
christmas movies most of them have
almost identical plots a businesswoman
moves to a small town and she meets her
high school sweetheart and she realizes
that business isn't everything love is
everything and then she stays in her
hometown forever but then there's some
christmas movies where they try to do
something that's never been done before
but in order to do that because
everything's been done before you have
to come up with the most insane plot i
just watched one where these mannequins
came to life and were like falling in
love with the people in the movie and it
was such a bizarre film
where does drew gooden
get his joke i get my joke from right
here
is drew gooden good in i'd like to think
i'm good
i haven't
done any crimes
is drug and canadian no i'm not i am a
floridian and american and you might be
thinking of curtis connor my friend he's
canadian he gets associated with me and
danny a lot but no i'm not canadian
is drew gooden
a vegetarian i like vegetables i did a
video recently where i ate like tom
brady for a month and i ate a lot of
vegetables when i did that
but he still eats like fish so i ate
fish too so i never went full vegetarian
but if it's something i could commit to
i'd be happy to do it you know
is drew gooden a dolphins fan
yes i
just like the orlando magic i am also a
fan of the miami dolphins another
florida team that is pretty bad at the
sport that they play for the most part
you know some people get to grow up and
they watch their favorite team win super
bowls and championships and playoff
games and all these things and i've
never seen
um
any of my favorite teams have success is
drew gooden in euphoria
no i'm not in euphoria i'm not zendaya
either i don't know if that's what
they're asking about i wish she's the
best but no i'm not
i guess what i want people to take away
from the wired autocomplete interview is
that even though me and the other drew
gooden get our information mixed up a
lot on youtube we're different dudes
okay
he's much taller than me